Hey guys what's up this is going to be my
Snoke episode 8 video.
Just talking about the Backstory that they've
explained so far.
There a lot of great theories about Snoke.
There's the mace windu theory I'll do videos
for that stuff too but that's a little crazier,
this is based on the information that's actually
canon that they revealed there is a new round
of the Star Wars giveaway for IMAX tickets.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
If you're new to the channel, be sure to click
that bell to enable alerts I usually make
important announcements at the end of videos
most of what we know about Snoke's back story
comes through other characters back stories.
The aftermath book series for episode 7 they
were a couple novels that was aftermath aftermath
life debt that sort of explain what was going
on with the first order the lead-in to episode
7, so a lot of people asked why wasn't he
around during the original trilogy why didn't
they write him in the way their filling in
gaps in the cannon like they did during Rogue
one with the big weakness in the death Star
there sewing up a lot of the logic they haven't
said how old he is, but they did say that
he's a humanoid alien he's not a former human
he used to be handsome that was twisted by
the dark side of the force.
He had that giant scar running down his four
head Clelia battle he has sort of like a burn
mark that causes them to speak in a funny
way, so you know that through the practice
of the dark side of the force.
He got into battles was scarred that survived
in is now the de facto leader for the opposition
to the Jedi.
So we still have Jedi because Luke Skywalker
still exists there was the new Jedi order
he was part of another group of Dark-side force
users that were not associated with the sit
rose up after the fall of the Emperor we knew,
Princess Leia was aware of him during the
rise of the new Republic knew he was a Dark-side
force user knew that her son Ben was susceptible
to that chose not to warn Han Solo about him
because she felt it was her duty to protect
her son because she was force sensitive, she
wanted him with Luke.
There were a lot of those moments during the
force awakens where you get the sense that
she made a lot of errors that led to her and
Han Solo splitting a paper like how come there
divorce how can they not together anymore,
but they really brushed over a lot of those
details in episode 7, but it's all there in
the expanded material.
He was here.
Every time you look at me reminded of him.
You think I want
to forget him back too much for wanting to
change the deal went back to the only thing
I was a single source for it to Snoke.
He seduced her son to the dark side, but we can
still save him. Me, you.
The other really interesting detail
is that Leia and everyone else he the identity
of Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader from Ben
growing up.
They didn't let him know that his grandfather
was Darth Vader.
He knew he was a Skywalker, but for some reason
they were able to shroud the truth from him
Leia's opposition inside the new Republic.
She had political enemies use that information
against her.
So she was forced to tell him; he felt abandoned, lied to.
That's when Snoke was able to turn into the
dark side of the force, but he was also able
to take control of the first order as it continued
to rise.
They explained through Leia story in all these
aftermath books in the lead up to episode
7 that she saw the threat of the remnants
of the Empire of the new Republic wasn't taking
it seriously didn't take the first order seriously
So that's what she left and formed
the resistance to try and fight than independently
and for a brief period
The new Republic would help them out. One of
the biggest reasons why the first order targeted
those worlds that were populated by the new
Republic was a cut off all the support and
resources they were giving to the resistance.
So based on the hierarchy a lot of people
also think that Snoke is somebody that we've
seen in the expanded material, but he hasn't
become Snoke or taken that name.
We know that he's an alien humanoid but we
don't know what his name was before it was
Snoke.
We don't know if he has another name there
was an imperial general character in the life
debt booked a lot people think secretly was
Snoke, called Gallius Rax. He's this Fleet Admiral
with the first order with the remanats of
the Empire who forms the shadow Council and
becomes is very powerful figure, so a lot
of people feel like he might turn out to be
Snoke.
He has this mysterious name called the operator,
but the whole reason for that is it is just
really hard for somebody who has no association
with the Empire or the first-order to Roland
and completely take control of everything
we know that Snoke performed a new Darkseid
order just like the church of the force was
formed.
There is a mysterious character named Tosh
you who's a Darkseid historian that pops up
during the aftermath series just like Lor
San Teca during the force awakens was this
figure who serves the force you have people
who serve the dark side of the force that
we just haven't seen a lot of yet that will
see during episode 8 so Snoke up using these
people.
And new recruits to form the nights of rent
has this special new order of Dark side force
users he had an apprentice before been Skywalker
was briefly mention you don't know a lot about
him.
But then he became obsessed with the lineage
of Darth Vader thinking that he would be a
focal point in the force in the really cool
thing about this new Darkseid order that we
learn it.
They call themselves acolytes of the beyond
the beyond part means beyond the galaxy as
we know it.
So if you read the expanded universe there
are things that come from outside the known
universe.
There's the unknown regions their places of
space within the Star Wars universe the just
haven't been mapped very well so little palpitating
back story he felt like a lot of his power
came from somewhere beyond the galaxy.
Now he believed in the force in a very broad
way, but it just teasing the idea that were
going to be seeing things from outside the
galaxy as we know it.
But by all accounts as powerful a Darks side
force user is Snoke gives he was just a normal
person that became twisted by the dark side
of the force physically but is very different
from palpitating in his approach to how the
first-order works like when the star killer
base blows up.
He doesn't care he just very calm bring Kylo
Ren to meet it's time to finish his training
fuel cells of the collapse of the place since
come to Scott over time just the Emperor was
very proud of both the stars is really big
on washing himself of a motion which is kind
of controversial because the Darkseid is all
about embracing that emotion, but a lot of
people inside the first-order as well as Snoke
felt like the Empire was just as responsible
for its downfall as the rebels were this is
really cool quote from Snoke to Kylo Ren is
the talking to each other about the downfall
of the Empire and his grandfather Darth Vader.
He says it was neither poor strategy nor arrogance
that brought down the Empire.
You know too well what did in Kylo Ren nods
and says sentiment Snoke replies yes had Lord
Vader not succumbed to a motion at the crucial
moment had the father killed the son the Empire
would have prevailed and there would be no
threat of Skywalker's return today, so you
learn that smoke is very worried about Luke
Skywalker coming back probably turning Kylo
Ren back to the light side of the force that
he also teaches Kylo Ren that emotion in sentiment
are very bad things.
That's why he showed so much concern when
Kylo Ren was trying to track down the money
and falcon because he will be facing his father
would be an extremely sentimental moment so
you can see that his politics as well as his
approach to the dark side of the force is
very different from the emperors.
So that's the whole idea he still meant to
be a very ambiguous character just so they
can continue to explore that in the new movies,
but when they say that Snoke is a brand-new
character Andy Serkis said this is a character
you haven't seen before is just a new character
that they're weaving into the Canon they haven't
explained exactly how old he is, but he has,
parity with the Emperor a lot of people felt
like going and episode 7 there were rumors
that he would be this ancient person on the
edges of the force.
When it was announced that Andy Serkis would
be doing motion capture a lot of people felt
like he was going to be some crazy hulking
figure at the hologram just makes him look
that big 25 feet tall.
In reality he still very tall like parity
with Darth Vader who was over 7 feet tall.
So very, very tall in his armor, but not quite
as tall as Chewbacca, so hopefully that explains
a little about Snoke's origins why he was
a part of the Emperor's counsel why he's not
a character that we've seen before.
Mostly to keep him mysterious that they will
leave him.
And once they explain his back story someone
from within the Empire who had a lot of political
clout was able to build a following and seize
control of the first order in the chaos that
was the end of the Empire the really cool
detail.
I think though is the idea that Princess Leia
was aware of him the whole time.
So he's not somebody that just came out of
nowhere, so that sort of like a gap in the
logic of the franchise right now that they'll
sew up once they explain it.
So he used to look much more humanoid they
refer to him as being handsome.
So you could imagine him looking just like
any other person that he was in a humanlike
the Emperor from Nabu he was alien humanoid
what I'll probably do for one of my next Star
Wars bonus videos is talk about the new force
order that he's trying to create.
They call them force warriors not Jedi not
sith something completely new in between both
of those things great Jedi is probably the
best comparison that I could make, but a lot
of people said that Gray Jedi aren't canon
anymore but I will do a video on grade Jedi.
Nonetheless just to explain, there are certain
force users to practice ideas that are somewhere
between the dark side and the light side of
the force like they tried to harness everything
in a slightly different context to what the
Jedi order taught.
There's a whole lot of the mythology that
we have to talk about this can be really exciting
this year but though slowly tease details
out as we get new trailers there's rumors
that will get teasers both for celebration,
but I think the first episode 8 real trailer
will drop at Star Wars celebration this year.
Congratulations to the new Star Wars giveaway
winner A-Train game please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a Star Wars video while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here to
learn more about episode 8 and you can click
here to learn more about Luke Skywalker.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you in the next video!